good morning believe nation today's
message is learn it all over to you Tony
Hawk
I wake up every morning express little
TV go what is it that [ __ ] real special
Club I just enter it what why not put an
arrow stop skating my name is a
narrative of highest say five years in
cave i have skating tottenham give a
kind of um so i have that you know that
consistency but i think that for me i
really like learning new techniques you
know and a lot of people if they're
skiing you stick with this this one
style TN is one you know set of tricks
and don't want to branch out because
they're afraid of won't they won't look
cool doing it ever come I always wanted
to try the different techniques even if
I someone I knew and it would help me be
more well-rounded that's probably what
it is one giant learn learned all I
think it's really important to
understand where innovation comes from
if you're an entrepreneur you want to
cope with these new innovative ideas you
want to break through in your market has
something that's really different
understand where innovation comes from
because most of the time innovation just
comes from connecting the dots that
other people haven't seen before by
looking at different industries
different businesses different cultures
and seeing how things work there or way
over here the nobody's thought of before
not even on camera and bringing it back
to what you're doing Steve Jobs famously
came up with fonts in the personal
computing industry and that's what
helped sell his first line of computers
what Steve Jobs wasn't the first person
think about farts and importance of
writing and writing style and the impact
that that has he just took a well-known
science the people acknowledged the
importance of relevancy of it and just
brought it to this new field of
computers over here he just lined up
those two things that nobody had
connected those dots before that's what
you need to do this is where you have
the ability to really stand out from
everybody else around you by connecting
the dots are the things that you love
that nobody else has those combinations
of love I love business I love you too I
love league of legends
I love the Toronto Blue Jays and
baseball I love salsa dancing I combine
all of these things into a business that
nobody else can replicate it's why you
can't out Evan Evan it's why when people
just copy me for exactly what I'm doing
they're never going to win they're not
going to innovate they're just copycats
I don't care about the car I don't look
behind I don't care about blocking the
copycat people I'm looking forward and
you need to do the same all of your
interests all of your passions
everything that you've ever liked you
can combine all those ideas to make an
amazing unique different special
valuable business when I took over a
charlatan south side beginner this year
as the owner I brought a whole bunch of
things to the salsa industry that has
never been seen before I'm bringing
aspects of YouTube and entrepreneurship
and baseball and League of Legends and
all the things that I care about into
this business that nobody else can
replicate because they don't have the
same passions and is they're just trying
to copy me they're going to fail the way
for them to win is to go more in on
their strengths in the things that they
care about and find a way to integrate
that into their business this is how you
are going to wane as an entrepreneur
stop trying to copy everybody else find
the connective tissue between seemingly
unrelated industries hobbies passions
and find a way to make it work combine
the genius of the and that's where
you're going to have success do it now
think about what you love to do what
your hobbies are what your passions are
the people i think is weird or different
or odd how you spend your spare time
were you like to go on vacation what can
you pull from all of those things to
instantly make your business better
figure that out you've got some magic
ingredients for an amazing business so
the question today today is I'm curious
what have you learned from a different
industry that seemed totally irrelevant
but then you applied it to your business
and it worked super curious to find out
leave in the comments below I'm going to
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to brittney
robinson from treehouse game publishing
com britney thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word it you
really really really means a lot to me
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso hey believe nation were
also looking at making a top 10 up Tony
Hawk he was a quick sneak peek of some
of the clips were thinking of including
I hope you enjoy let me know what you
think when I started our company
birdhouse in the first three years in we
were ready to give it you know with the
sales just wasn't weren't there the the
interest wasn't there um and same with
my skating like i was i was still
improving my skills but for no audience
um so it was definitely difficult but
but we embrace those challenges too
especially as athletes I mean you
someone someone poses a challenge to you
and you have to figure out how to get
over it and so in in doing that in my
skating and also in the business it was
like well these are what's this is
what's coming at us we've got to figure
out how to navigate this and how to
succeed and a lot of people just give up
oh yeah and especially in skating I mean
that's the first sign of someone that's
going to be successful is no matter how
far no matter how successful they get
especially in competition they continue
to challenge themselves because they
want to improve those are the guys that
make it way further than I would have
when you come up with new ideas for what
is it as you do how to get into the zone
that's translated than in the business
world and how you come up with that next
step that's innovation shop would you
want to get out cause everybody else oh
I think it's uh that means how many
comments it's just when i ran for
something safe new trick hi I know I
still
here instance to do it I know that I
visualized and now you do it same goes
for business you know I know like we did
it to her it's called real intention
progress was big part of that is here he
comes oh we did sir which was escaping
an XLR cross I visualize the whole thing
is that you know them we have our
sorcerer popular enough that we don't
have to get sideshow to talk to her
anymore we don't have to leave the
halftime show to the loggia we can we
can get our own crowd we have honor of
marrying into her neck design handsome
son oh she's the main on napkin customer
bucks find that and it was the filtering
for it including walk across
skateboarding ms I just knew that that
would work I knew that there were enough
kids out there that would love him see a
show they will see what our soldiers
entertainment it was about competition
was actually my transition being a
competitor to being a performer and then
I never thought what doesn't work with
so that's what everyone comes like
that's that's what guilty because you
live in that world out and it comes to
fruition and you can't you can't think
that way you just you know you know some
you love and we essentially think it's
going to work but you have to go out and
say you will work and see it here
sometimes it takes years I get so busy I
forget to stop and say wow I'm actually
living the dream and I think that for
all you guys you know going to college
and and aspiring to do something you'll
find yourself completely busy and
overwhelmed at times and if you just
stop and look around go well I'm
actually doing this you know this is
kind of what I had in mind it's just
that you get so you get so caught up in
the whirlwind of it you don't realize
that you got to just stop and think wow
this is it I appreciate it I want to
figure out how it could remove myself in
competition and still be a pro skater
and that had not been done yet um
because if you're not going to compete
the magazine's aren't going to cover you
your sponsors are likely to drop you and
the
kids who are buying your products are
going to forget about you and there was
no such thing as a video skater back
then that hadn't really come into play
yet there was no YouTube you know the
skate videos were usually based on the
the best guys in the competitions and so
I went talked to Stacie a new was your
boss at the stacy peralta was my coach
and and I actually had my brother come
with me as backup and he you know he
approached a season looks Tony's really
having a problem with with the
competition's it's you know it's kind of
wrecking him it's ruining the fun of
skating and I told him that and so he
said well you know I understand maybe
you might want to take a break but don't
give it up completely because you may
want to come back he may be you know you
may enjoy it and I don't know if we're
going to be able to sustain your career
if you're not competing and I did take a
break my stopped competing for a while
almost a year maybe a little less and
when I came back to it I came back with
sort of a fresh perspective that I don't
really care how it lays out I'm gonna go
and do my best and I'm going to take
chances that I maybe hadn't taken before
and if thats puts puts me in last place
then I so be it but if if it's if I
succeed i'm going to be on this whole
other level of skating mm-hmm and that's
what happened I mean and the contest
that I one then I won by a long shot you
know because I was doing stuff that was
experimental and stuff that I wasn't
really confident with but but I could
pull it through somehow and if it didn't
happen then I didn't do well at all and
I stopped caring about the end result so
much